on the bounds for the diamondbacks today
it's madison bumgarner his second start
since he was reinstated from the injured
list last week after left shoulder
trouble now mad bum right now ranks
100th on the all-time strikeout list
he's nine behind josh beckett so
hopefully he'll pass josh beckett in the
ball game today against the buckos well
it's one thing to play center field
after catching the previous game but for
dalton varsha he's doing it day game
after a night game we asked tori about
this before the game today and he said
hey he's young he'll be fine
for crying out loud
and sends this out to center right away
the test for the young vars show and
he's got it 3-2 pitch
one more time for varsho
[Applause]
and some loud contact they're going to
keep varsho busy out there way out there
in right center and dalton runs it down
and it'll be max craddock getting his
third major league start what a birthday
present for young max yeah absolutely
max comes into the game he's working
that that heavy fastball he's been
throwing a lot of spin on it as that
four pitch mix with the slider curve
ball and his changeup that he likes to
use
went back to 95
and it'll line out to left
unafraid he was no matter
who was up there hitting
that's a big yard
and oliva uses just about uh
every inch of it and krannik not phased
center of the pitch and they're swinging
a flat ball at the left there it is
oliver
waiting on it to come down he'll make
the catch and the inning ends two out
single left stranded jacob stalin slits
it off and the first pitch here is hit
in the air to left field backing up is
david peralta still going back at the
wall
oh he's got it the freight train took
one away
89 center of the strike zone that time
cast it high in the air david with a
couple looks at the wall
little jump right there catches it right
at the top of the yellow stripe that
time
looks like that might have been gone
yeah i think so
some home run robbery by the gold glover
out there david peralta
jared oliva out of the university of
arizona
that ball into right field polanco
will be
able to score without a throw in jared
oliva
and his family loves it
his second career rbi is off madison
bumgarner in a one-nothing lead
holiday got to start behind the plate
monday against pittsburgh and brian on
monday singled and doubled in that bowl
game
holiday
left center and we're tied at one
that's brian holliday's third hit this
series
left center field boy starting paving
smith on that ground ball yeah by dalton
marshall ends up getting a run for the
diamondbacks they avoided the double
play he was able to advance to third
base
and to center field there's that busy
marshall
frazier's going to try and move up
and he will only because the ball was
not caught by rojas
trying to get the lead back for the
pirates
[Music]
is there enough room
yes
frazier will tag
and move up 90 more feet now with two
outs
nice catch by
cole calhoun
hard to third escobar smothers it
got him eduardo escobar saves a run
and that ends the third long throw by
adela pika but he gets the big nigowski
and we're still tied at one
[Music]
so here's the cleanup man david perrault
rojas at third with two outs
down the line that's a fair ball
diamondbacks have the lead and here goes
the freight train
he'll stop at second make it an rbi
double and it's two to one
on david's swing earlier in the ball
game much more aggressive when he's
hitting the ball now it's making a loud
noise off the bat
hooking ground ball down that first base
line into the corner for an rbi double
two on one out two to one arizona
pirates batting in the fourth inning
well that's bounced oh off the glove of
escobar
he taketh away he giveth and the pirates
score two to take the lead i didn't see
the bad hop i was wondering
where it was
well it hopped off his glove that's set
off
yep
alanko in right field to the track hits
off the glove marshall had to hold up
tony parizhika going to wave him around
no throw
and we're tied at three
that carry that was hit a lot harder
than gregory polanco thought
with the bases loaded frazier
hayes
reynolds he dressed down his team in the
dugout and he walked him four pitches
and tied again on four pitches
that's it right there goes by him they
get one and two
play right there by nick ahmed but
the pirates get the equalizer and we're
tied it forward
now the diamox will send up payment
smith to lay things off
even smith hits a fly ball deep to right
field
and it's gone
haven smith homework monday a home run
this afternoon that's his fourth this
month
his ninth of the year and it's 5-4 d-bag
they get the lead right back
marshall bidding for one
polanco at the wall
that's gone
back-to-back d-backs and it's six to
four dalton reaches out hits it high in
the air to right field
polanco trying to measure he thinks he
has a chance to make a play here but out
of his reach
well i mentioned varsha with that drive
to the opposite field that doubly hit
back in the fourth inning turns this one
around to right
field oh we got a top shelf josh
takes a base it away from newman
[Applause]
was hit off the hands a little bit
wasn't scalded out there in that
direction so josh had to time that leap
perfectly to get up their top shelf and
take a base it away
hayes drives one to right field old
calhoun is there diamondbacks get the
win 6-4 they've won four straight games
and they get the three-game sweep